thing also about Detroit being in that
game you talk about the Victor
winbanyama sweepstakes yes and the three
the three worst teams in the league will
all have equal opportunity uh in the
lottery
um
to get him and those three worst teams
right now are Houston San Antonio and
Detroit and it will end that way yeah
and um yeah Charlotte is right there on
the on the outskirts of that too but
um here's the latest on Victor
wendbanyama uh a 22.17 rebound six block
four Steel game give me that against the
Czech Republic well I mean he's a
special talent because of his ability to
handle the ball and shoot the ball yeah
but at that size you know we can't
everybody wants this kid he looks like
he's great but you really can't tell
until you get to the NBA well you know
we said that about some great players
that you know yeah did it yeah and like
only one I'm a great right away and that
was LeBron I just think that his skill
set is is the way he scores even in the
European game is very similar to where
he'd be scoring in the NBA so I don't
think it'll be an adjustment it's not
like I think there's been errors where
guys have had to change their game and
add something to it
um this kid shoots the three handles the
ball gets into areas of the floor seven
foot five he's going to shoot over you
not many guys can really defend him and
the ball handling is what makes him
special to me it's not the anything else
but his ability to handle the bathroom
and I don't agree with all that I think
it's going to be a huge adjustment the
first the physicality
you take the NBA physical now I think
it's going to be more physical he's
playing against the Czech Republic I
mean he's going to be playing against
grown men and he's gonna have to guard
those guys on the other end also which
going to bring him into foul trouble
it's not going to be this no listen I've
been in NBA for 40 years I ain't seen
But one guy
one guy who didn't go to college who
came in who was ready and that's LeBron
Kobe was great he struggled early Kevin
Garnett was great he struggled early
Dwight Howard still struggling in Taiwan
um just joking Dwight I'm not mad I
don't even keep up with that I didn't
know I'm not a crazy like Shaq but will
Victor be great at some point I don't
know the answer to that I can't I don't
so you said struggled in great
struggling great struggling yeah I know
that no but see this is what I hate
Jack idiots like us
we spent all our time excuse me
clarification Jack idiot because you
won't let me say jackass
Okay so yes yeah so Ernie this is one of
my biggest problem with people who do
our job
we like you know they got to debate why
can't we just enjoy Michael Jordan's and
LeBron greatness and Kobe's and kareems
like
it's going to play itself out you know
like he's the next this he's the next
set like how many people did Michael
Jordan kill
I mean we've been for the last 40 years
like well he's the next Michael Jordan
and we never had another one and we
killed like uh how how Harold Miner uh
uh Roy marble like all these guys
supposed to be I I want to see the kid
play I hope he's great he's great for
our job but I can't sit here now just
cause he's killing people over in the
Czech Republic that he's going to come
over here and dominate I just don't
believe yeah I I didn't I I would say
you're 100 right in that let it play out
but also our job is projection
like so in terms of when I watch college
players coming into the NBA I have a
projection right what they could be his
projection is much higher than any
college player that's fair and again
much higher but but just for the second
uh for the record I've been right quite
a few times and I've been wrong quite a
few times I've been more right than
wrong well listen let's don't talk about
the stat sheet again 22 17 six blocks
and four steals back with